the beverly hills 90210 cast is
responding to jessica alba's claim
that she was not allowed to make eye
contact with the cast
when she guest starred on the show in
1998.
yeah so i talked to jason percy this
morning on my radio show which is the
razamoka show across the country
and uh jenny garth and tori spelling
weighed in on on their new 9021 omg
podcast
but first let's remind you what jessica
said on hot ones
on the set of 90210 i couldn't even make
eye contact
with any of the cast members which was
really strange
when you're like trying to do a scene
with them
yeah i was like you're not allowed to
make eye contact with any one of the
cast members or you'll be thrown off
throughout the set i don't know who told
jessica alba
not to look at us like like look none of
us on that show were
we never thought we were m.c hammer
great line by the way that's awesome i
love it so but do you think though like
i guess i'm wondering because you
you guys were so incredibly wildly
like famous like sneaking out of hotels
and laundry bins and everything else
do you think that people within your
world
did that preemptively because they
thought that that's what you guys wanted
yeah there is a very
slight possibility that someone and
i mean apparently somebody did because
they thought
that maybe that was the thing to do i
look i really i you know i don't know i
don't know what jessica alba's
experience was
coming on our show as a guest star i
know that i know that certainly
you know you know i never would have
made her feel that way
like i you know i was i always went out
of my way to make sure that our guest
stars felt incredibly welcome and i
would always
go and talk to them and you know make
sure that they were they they knew that
this was a place where we wanted them to
succeed and
um because because because i because i
knew that i you know i've been on enough
sets as a guest star and i you know i
always really appreciated it
when the regulars on the show came and
made me feel that way so i was
go i always went out of my way back then
and i still do to this day
i make sure that the guest stars feel
like they're a part of the show and
you know like that's super important so
i don't know what happened
to jessica alba when she was i don't
even know if i i think i don't even
think i worked with her like she was in
a storyline that
that i had nothing to do with so i i
don't know what her experience was on
the show and i'm
i'm sorry that that happened to her tori
did you i just need to know did you tell
her not to look me in the eye
why is it all about you well because i
had all the scenes with her like if
anybody was
you know not didn't want to have their
eyes looked into it would have been me
but
i don't remember because i have the
world's worst memory
so i'm just wondering if there was some
like cool memo that was like going
around
from the producers or the eds
and we didn't even know imagine we just
thought like guest stars didn't like
they us looked at us we don't know why
we were so nice
okay noah says i don't even remember her
on 90210 she was only on i think
two episodes maybe three episodes nelson
says it's not the cast that told her
shell says that's so brutal
but as he says nano two and o'cas
thought they were hot beep
so i believe it um there was one more um
i i lost now these yeah these are the
years
yeah yeah uh these were the years
that um later on so shannon doherty was
gone
luke perry wasn't even on the show
anymore these were the sort of later
years
in in 90210 but you know this happens
and and this whole you know don't look
at people in the eyes this isn't a 90210
exclusive
we just had this conversation last week
you know about ellen and
and you know sort of directives go down
you know i've been
in a i've been in an atmosphere
no joke where a superstar
singer was about to leave the dressing
room and not even to go on stage
and the hallway was cleared like we it
was either turn your back
or go in this room if you couldn't if
you couldn't fit in another room
to get them to get them down the hall
and i've been told by people
to not look at people before so is this
a thing that happens
yes it's absolutely a thing that happens
but is it always
directed from the actual star i would
say less than 50 percent
and more so it's somebody justifying
what they do for a living
which is managing the super famous and
so i believe
jeff i believe jason priestley i you
know i believe you know jenny and
and tori you know that this was not
necessarily their thing
but maybe it's people that did it on
their behalf
yeah it's funny that i first heard the
jenny tori
clip and i was like well that was a
non-answer because jenny's basically
saying
i don't remember something pretty
major to forget that you told cast
members not to look at you like
both both ways you need to remember you
never
told someone to not look at you or you
remember the other way so i i hated that
answer i don't remember
either way and then tori kind of gives a
non-answer as well so i appreciated
jason's answer that he gave you because
that was an actual answer because yeah
the other two didn't really
say anything so yeah like you said it
could have been a good cup bad cup
situation that
you know a publicist or whatever someone
on the crew told them not to look at
them and it was coming from the cast
member
or it was the crew member going rogue
and telling a guest star but once again
we talked about this the other day
i don't get how you do it with someone
that you're gonna do scenes with
so like what jessica alba is supposed to
look down when they're not on camera and
as soon as cameras are rolling like okay
now you can look at jenny garth
like that like guess what the situation
was
yes because they're they're i mean this
is this is not a new thing this is
something that happens all the time
but this goes back to when we were
talking about alan because i the thing
that i would find peculiar
and is you know with the the rules on
alan which were supposedly nobody talks
at nobody talks to and nobody looks at
ellen
those were the the sort of directives
and why there's a part of me that does
believe that some of this at least
does come from the stars in question
which is if you were
at work one day and every other
person in that building no longer looked
at you and no longer spoke to you
how long do you think it would be to
take you before you would look at me and
go
what's the matter with everybody like
did i do something wrong does like
everybody
hate me no you would ask that
immediately
if you were suddenly nobody talked to
you and nobody looked at you you would
think you did something wrong so that
sort of
this whole thing where i do find that
maybe there's a little bit
of that but i think that when you look
at how famous everybody was
on 90210 at that time because they were
like they were bts kind of famous like
they were crazy famous at the time
and i i think that this is just years of
you know i don't have a lot of time to
sit and talk about
everything with everybody that i meet so
just usher me out
tell people not to talk to me i don't
want to be put in situations that are
uncomfortable i just want to come in
and do my job and this may be one of
those directives
that's attached to that and i i don't
know but i love jason priestley and
you know he just you know i don't know i
don't know i don't know what happened
but even like but even that's even like
that's lesser degree like even what
jason was saying is like oh i was made
to try like every
guest star make them feel so welcome
like that's one thing and there wouldn't
be days like you don't feel like
you don't like oh i don't feel like
going and having a five minute gets no
conversation when i get started like i
get that perspective like you wouldn't
want to do it every day sometimes you're
having a day
you just want to do the scene and that's
that's fine like that's their
prerogative
but no saying don't look at me that's a
whole other degree
like no i'm not gonna have a five minute
conversation with you and get to know
you
to don't look at me those are those are
two very no
thanks god even to just even to just say
those words like
it's so mind-blowing to me because again
again this does happen i've been in the
situation where this happens
but i just cannot believe i don't even
know how you would ask that of somebody
i don't know how you would even approach
the conversation of
hey listen can you make sure nobody
looks at me
yeah like that is a lot to have of
another person
to control that like your job right now
is to make sure nobody
looks at me like that is incredibly huge
yeah i will say i said the other day too
is like
jessica i'll be experiencing this so
early in the career and the fact that
she's held on to that all these years
like i hope she learned that lesson that
you know people are going to hold on to
stories about how i act on set so i need
to be careful
how i act myself so i hope she's taken
that philosophy going forward in her
career
what i'm just saying i hope it was a
good life lesson
i i also agree with you
but there are many that do not
just no i'm just saying i wish i hoped
there was life left
i'll just i'll just leave it there i i i
started hearing as soon as this story
came
as soon as this story came out my inbox
filled up with people
who said i wish i could go on hot ones
and talk about jessica alba
cheers